versailles s'impose enfin domicile cette
saison ce samedi 22 octobre les bleus et
roses ont dominé saint-ouen l'aumône
dans leur gymnase bonbons à l'occasion
de la 6e journée du championnat de
prénationale après une grosse première
période remportée c'est à dix les
versaillais ont accentué leur avance
pour s'imposer 34 à 24 sur le match on a
dominé dès le début je pense que surtout
en défense on avoue montré beaucoup
d'envié du coup le gardien ils ont fait
beaucoup d'arrêts par rapport à aux
matches précédents et c'est là dessus
qu'on a gagné le match et après en
forcément défendant bien bas ça ça me
fait récupérer des ballons je joue un
jeu rapide nos forces cela fonctionne et
c'est que les joueurs avaient vraiment
envie de gagner ont écouté mes consignes
début à la fin on avait un plan de jeu
sur la première mi temps soit très
limité en fonction du changement de côté
terreur et des changements de penser
qu'on pouvait avoir aidé par qu'on avait
le plan de jeu a été respecté on avait
aussi de défense possible à ces hausses
sont à 5 avec des joueurs différents on
a le terme est beaucoup pour que tout le
monde souffle et qu'on puisse maintenir
un rythme sur le jeu rapide
cette victoire permet à versailles de
mettre fin à une série de quatre
défaites consécutives et de remonter au
classement et genre d' alexandre
taillefer occupe désormais la septième
place à huit points du leader plaisir
espère toujours monter cette saison mon
objectif était la montée la plus
problématique c'est que il ya trois
clubs de l'us métro rouille et plaisir
qu'ils sont également renforcés donc la
montée on le savait jeu m'avait dit au
groupe allait être beaucoup plus dur
cette année que l'année dernière elle
s'avère on a eu
des joueurs blessés en début de saison
ce des absents pour diverses raisons
travail vacances ce qui nous a fait
qu'on a été à jouer même jusqu'à même
pas en plus une fin de match à 12 le
week-end dernier une fois qu'on sera
maintenu on verra si on peut se placer
le plus haut possible pour continuer à
attirer des joueurs pour éventuellement
une montée l'année prochaine prochain
match pour les versailles et le samedi
12 novembre contre bruno à l'extérieur
une équipe à égalité de points avec les
joueurs de la cité royale
[Applaudissements]